[Musique]
non
quand je passe vers les clients et que
leur demande si tout s'est bien passé et
qu'il me dise ce plat m'a rappelé un
souvenir d'il ya 20 30 ans ou que
j'avais pas évoqué depuis longtemps
cela m'a procuré un orgasme on a été
jusque là je me dis c'est ça le sens mon
sens ma façon de voir les choses c'est à
dire de comprendre que le repas peut
apporter les émotions pas porter de
grandes émotions
pour moi toutes les belles plus belles
histoires ont une fin et faillit m non
pas le fin et filien c'est à dire la
conclusion mais pour moi la fin le début
la fin c'est l'appétit mais la fin c'est
aussi lanville envie d'avancer l'envi de
se construire et l envie de partager
beaucoup des moments de partage de
cuisine j'en ai eu beaucoup je pense de
tout ce que je peux me souvenir j'ai
toujours voulu être cuisinier toujours
quand j'étais petit j'étais avec ma
grand-mère et on à led et quelquefois
fin on était tous les deux ou trois que
mon grand-père et puis c'est odeur de
pomme ça va peut-être appeler beaucoup
de choses à beaucoup de monde cette
odeur de pomme qui caramélise je faisais
moi-même des tartes aux pommes
ma grand mère s'occupait du curé de la
paroisse étaient voisins et je faisais
j'avais sept ou huit ans je faisais des
tartes aux pommes pour pour le curé
c'est j'en ai encore plein la bouche les
pommes qui caramélise la pâte qu'ont
mangé cru on se faisait taper sur les
mains mais c'était tellement des changes
et un jour un dimanche 7 août à bella il
m'appelle il appelle ma grand-mère et
disent vraiment pas là mathieu et il dit
c'était très très bon félicitations
monsieur régaler un petit peu plus de 30
ans je m'en souviens encore j'ai encore
le son de sa voix dans mon oreille le
plaisir l'émotion que ça peut procurer
j'ai aussi souvenir quand j'étais chez
mes parents enfin quand je suis le cadet
mes parents étaient agriculteurs
mais j'étais le cadet de la famille j'ai
aussi souvenir des odeurs ma maman
cuisine est beaucoup caramélise est rôti
sait tous et tous ses goûts toutes ces
odeurs tous qui parfume la maison et que
nous
envoûte ça m'a beaucoup marqué ça m'a
marqué à jamais j'en ai encore l'eau à
la bouche
j'essaie légère odeur qui parcourt la
maison qui sont encore dans ma tête le
plaisir l'émotion le sens que ça a pour
moi être très important après venu le
temps de la formation le temps de la
formation au lycée hôtelier juste à côté
à saint nazaire à sainte anne
le temps aussi où j'ai découvert que
c'était ma voie j'ai découvert
l'exigence de ce métier mais j'ai aussi
découvert a surtout découvert le plaisir
de ce métier le plaisir de donner le
sens de ma vie le sens qui est de
partager quelque chose partagez le
l'heureux pas être assis autour d'une
table
mais j'ai découvert aussi dans mon
immersion professionnelle le fait que
quand on n'est pas passionné par quelque
chose quand on est passionné par son
travail et bien la magie tombe
mes premières expériences
professionnelles de stages ou quoi que
ce soit était un petit peu plus un petit
peu plus mesuré dans la mesure où la
passion n'était pas là mais en jouant 80
18 je rencontre la passion je découvre
j'étais à la rochelle je m'en souviens
comme si c'était hier enfin 98 tout le
monde s'en souvient mais j'étais à la
rochelle et j'ai découvert monsieur
madame coutanceau et là j'ai vu le
plaisir j'ai vu l'émotion j'ai vu la
passion j'ai vu là la fin de la de la
découverte pour moi la découverte d'être
heureux de cuisine et d'être heureux de
servir et les gens étaient heureux
d'être présent les gens étaient heureux
de partager ce repas était heureux
d'être là et ça ça m'a vraiment marqué
et c'est resté comme un fil conducteur
dans ma vie après il ya une autre
expérience notamment paris calais nos
poubelles cité mais l'exigence aussi
l'excellence l'excellence qui doit vous
amener à toujours plus de raffinement
comprendre que on veut faire vivre des
moments d'exception à des gens la fin de
l'excellence la fin de la la fin des
filles aiment l'envié de se dépasser
avec eni calais non c'était ça avec
c'était la fin de se dépasser et d'avoir
des objectifs d'avoir des buts et d'y
arriver
c'était aussi l'époque un petit peu
palace ont été 70 cuisinier et
comprendre que le management le
leadership était très important
et que quand on est dans une cuisine
quand on est chef quand on est manager
dans cette cuisine quand on a chaque
parole compte chaque geste compte
chaque geste doit être précis chaque
geste doit être juste chaque parole doit
être juste parce que quand vous
réussissez à emmener 70 cuisiner avec
vous vous pouvez déplacer les montagnes
véritablement autour nar pas ça c'est
fondamental dans ma façon de voir les
choses
après d'autres expériences monsieur
putelat l'expérience de deux d'être chef
d'entreprise j'étais à carcassonne la
fin de la la persévérance la fin de cet
homme m'avait fait découvrir ce que ce
que peut être là je vois d'entreprendre
la liberté d'être chef de cuisine chefs
d'entreprise les responsabilités que ça
en incombe néanmoins le plaisir que vous
pouvez donner aux gens parce qu'ils sont
chez vous comme à la maison
et ça c'est très important c'est
véritablement très important il a été
lui jusqu'à être meilleur ouvrier de
france en 2018 en novembre dernier
d'autres m'ont accompagné d'autres j'ai
accompagné d'autres chefs pardon vers
ceux vers ce titre de meilleur ouvrier
de france monsieur philippe mille
notamment où là j'ai découvert
l'excellence la grande technicité et
avec lui le l'impact de du choix des
producteurs très important parce qu'on
est rien nous sommes qu'un maillon dans
une chaîne nous sommes que les
transformateurs soit mise en lumière
mais nous sommes des transformateurs et
ce qui est important ce qu'est
véritablement important c'est de
comprendre qu'il ya des producteurs des
produits comprendre que les gens qui
nous entourent les comprendre qu'il ya
des clients
ce chef philippe mille qui était
quelques années est devenue est lui
aussi meilleur ouvrier de france
tous les deux m'ont amené à moi même
concourir et puis avoir été en finale
ans en 2018 donc avec cette veste que je
portais que cela prenne enfin je leur
porte depuis depuis novembre 2018
avec cette allusion à monsieur robuchon
à monsieur bocuse c'était un grand
souvenir souvenir de l'excellent
souvenir on a la joie et la force de
chaque détail aujourd'hui dans mon
entreprise aujourd'hui dans mon
restaurant
j'essaie d'appliquer ça au jour le jour
dans mon management avec les gens qui
m'entourent il s'appelle claire il
s'appelle paul il s'appelle
adrien est également avec les
producteurs parce que c'est très
important très très important si on veut
donner il faut savoir comprendre si on
veut donner savoir comprendre comprendre
que quand je discute avec philippe
cirque et au clion sur mer quand il me
parle de ses carottes
j'ai juste l'impression que c'est lui
que je cuisine c'est même plus ses
carottes
il ya tellement une part de vie dans ces
carottes que c'est un bout de lui-même
que je que je cuisine quand je passe du
temps avec avec monsieur aux rockets qui
est un vigneron là-bas à rablay sur
layon effet du coteau du layon
quand il m'a dit à trois semaines je l'
ai vu il m'a dit mais tu comprends
mathieu on a joué on va perdre de la
récolte il y avait ses larmes j'ai
l'impression que c'est même pas ses ceps
de vignes qui avaient gelé c'était son
sens à lui qui avait gelé comprendre que
je ne suis qu'un transformateur qui me
faut mettre à la hauteur du produit à la
hauteur de ce produit de leurs produits
avec toute l'humilité que ça implique
et avec toute la responsabilité que ça
implique pour faire partager un moment
d'exception à un moment merveilleux un
moment goûteux aux gens qui m'entourent
aux gens qui m'entourent qui sont mes
clients
et puis mais quand la collaborateurs
même si j'aime pas utiliser ce terme les
gens qui est qu'ils sont vraiment avec
moi au restaurant et bien j'essaie
devoir d'exemplarité parce qu'on ne peut
pas être exigeant envers les autres si
on est soi même pas exigeant et ça c'est
très très important
exigeant dans le choix dans les mots
dans la réflexion sur les goûts exigent
aussi sur le fait d'être de recommencer
une fois deux fois trois fois mille fois
ci le plat va pas parce que la seule
chose qui compte c'est le client
on travaille tous pour le client je
travaille pour le client les clients
pour moi c'est à la vie à la mort parce
qu'ils sont juste de l'autre côté
l'autre côté du paravent et c'est une
pièce de théâtre où sont devant je suis
derrière
et l'idée c'est que on fasse qu'un
l'idée c'est qu'il comprenne ma cuisine
qu'ils comprennent que derrière ma
cuisine mais il ya une ramification une
multiplication
la plein plein plein plein plein de
petites choses qui sont importantes et
on essaye de rien laisser au hasard
ça c'est très très important alors là le
sens de tout ça pour moi c'est cette fin
cette fin dans vie cette fin de donner
cette fin de faire plaisir
cette fin de d'être avec vous cette fin
du main cette fin de rencontre
et cette fin d'excellence pour
comprendre que le moment du repas doit
être un moment de fête
je souhaite à tout le monde d'avoir
cette fin d'avoir cet appétit parce que
un moment donné c'est ça qui est
important
manger la vie à pleines dents bien sûr
comme on croque rainbow manger la vie
avec fin mongella vie avec envie toutes
les belles histoires d'une feinte et
faillit m parce que quand on a envie de
faire quelque chose et bien c'est
tellement plus quand on parle avec le
coeur c'est tellement plus et c'est un
petit peu le sens de ma vie où le sens
de mon actualité
je souhaite à tout le monde d'être
appétissant avec la vie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le bas